ينضم الينا الان من داخل مطار جيبوتي
مراسلنا جامع نور جامع اهلا بك عمليه
اجلاء رعايه اذا عده دول لا تزال متواصله
الى جيبوتي كيف تتابعها
نعم سفيان قبل قليل لا اقلعت طائره
يابانيه
تقل 48 من الرعايه اليابانيين اليابانيين
الذين تم
اجلارهم من من السودان وهذه هي الدفعه
الاولى لهذا الصباح بالامس وصل
طائرتين
عسكريتين تابعه لكندا الاولى كانت تحمل
خمسه واربعين من المواطنين السودانيين
اغلبهم من المواطنين السودانيين من حمله
الجنسيات الاخرى سواء بريطانيه او كنديه
او غيرها من الجنسيات الاوروبيه ايضا وصلت
بالامس
طائره اخرى عسكريه تقل اكثر من سبعين
شخصا تم اجراؤه من السودان ايضا اغلبهم
ايضا كانوا من السودانيين من دوري
الجنسيات
المزدوجه وصلوا البارحه وت نقلهم الى
المدينه في انتظار نقلهم بطائرات مدنيه
الى
البلدان سواء كندا او بريطانيا او او
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مطار جيبوتي
الدوله اصبح مرا
للرحلات التي تقل الرعايه الاجانب من
السودان ومنها بلدانهم الاصليه هناك كما
ترون
هناك طائره عسكريه كنديه ايضا هناك طائره
عسكريه طائرتين هذه واحده وهناك طائره
اخرى ترابط في هذا المطار على امل الذهاب
الى السودان وانزلاب مزيد من الرعايه
الجنوبيين فهناك بعض المعلومات التي حصلنا
عليها تشير الى امكانيه ان يصل مسايا هذا
اليوم
رحله اخرى
لكندا
الطائرات العسكريه الكنديه ستقل وتجلي
مواطنين من السودان لكن تتضح
الصوره في الساعات القليله القادمه معظم
الرعايه الذين يمرون يمرون عبر مطار
جيبوتي الدولي يمكثون سيتم نقلهم الى
المدينه او لمن لديه اعني لتلك الدول التي
لديها قواعد عسكريه في جيبوتي ينقل هؤلاء
الى تلك
القواعد العسكريه فيبقون هناك لفتره الى
حين ان تتجمع مجموعه يمكن ان ينقلوا دفعه
واحده الى بلدانهم الاصليه حركه وصول
هؤلاء هذه الرحلات الى جيبوتي هي ليست في
نفس الوتيره التي كانت عليها في الايام
ايام الازمه الاولى لكن لا زالت هناك
عمليات لوجستيه مكثفه في كل القواعد
العسكريه للدول التي لحق قواعد هناك ايضا
التنسيق ما بين حكومه جيبوتي وبين تلك
القوات وهذه الدول التي لازال هناك رعايه
لهم داخل السودان خمسه التقينا مع بعض
السودانيين الذين كانوا يحضرون الجنسيات
اخرى كنديه وبريطانيه وتحدثوا عن صعوبات
يواجهها الناس للوصول الى المناطق المخصصه
للاجلاء لان الطريق الى تلك المناطق يعني
ادارتها مقسمه ما بين الدعم السريع وما
بين الجيش السوداني وانه في نقاط التماس
ما بين هاتين القوتين المتقاتلتين دائما
ما تحدث يواجهون خطوره عند العبور في تلك
النقاط لانه لاتفه سبب
تندلع فيه مواجهات بين الطرفين سيؤثر سلبا
على حيات هؤلاء ايضا تحدثوا وقالوا لنا ان
هناك عدد كبير من المواطنين الذين
يرغبون في الخروج لكن الطريق طريق الخروج
اصبح صعبا للغايه ولا سيما واولئك الذين
لديهم اطفال او كبار السن يواجهون صعوبه
في الوصول الى تلك المناطق التي تم
تخصيصها
لاجرائك شكرا جزيلا لكم كنت معنا من داخل
مطار جيبوتي مراسلنا جام